We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David p here is a really interesting voicemail
from a, um, a about what waitstaff is doing
when Magda hat wearing Trumpists come in and,
uh, have a meal at this particular restaurant.
Take a listen to this.
Hey David.
How's it gone on calling from Missoula, Montana,
one of the more liberal bubbles maybe in Montana,
but I had an interesting thing happening at
my work lately and that's that some of my
employees are actually, uh, we work in the
service industry and they worked for tips
and we've kind of started this thing in my
work where if people come in were wearing
their mega hats, or we have certain local
Republican politicians that come and dine
with us, my servers are actually, they're
pledging the tips from those tables towards
Bernie Sanders campaign.
Anyways, I thought this was kind of a cool
idea and didn't know if you'd be interested
in maybe promoting this to some of your listeners
on your show that they could be a donating
service tips from Trump supporting people
or Republican politicians towards a progressive
candidate of their choice.
Listen, I absolutely love the idea.
This is extraordinary.
So Missoula, Montana, it's a red state, but
Missoula's is a little bit more of a purple
or bluish enclave within the state.
People come in wearing Maga hats rather than
treating them poorly or spitting in their
food or whatever.
The waitstaff says, the tips we get from the
mega hat wearing people and from the known
Republican politicians, we will and donate
to the campaign of Bernie Sanders who we believe
will achieve progressive change that we like
and that we are in favor of.
I love it.
I also understand that when you're getting
paid two 63 an hour, I believe it is in some
places plus tips.
The last thing I'm going to do is tell waitstaff
that they should jeopardize potentially their
own financial wellbeing by donating the, the
tips from Republican customers, the Bernie
Sanders.
So I love the idea and I think if more people
in the dining industry in the service industry
want to do it, absolutely more power to them.
But I also am extremely sensitive to the way
in which, um, so many people that work in
the service industry are really poorly compensated
and partially on the backs of the idea that
hey, we can, it should be okay for restaurant,
restaurant owners to pay them two 63 an hour.
Because in the end they are getting tips 15
20% from some customers, less from others.
More from others as well.
Uh, so I am not going to suggest that they
do anything with those tips other than, um,
use it to have a, hopefully a, a [inaudible]
in totality, a wage that is a living wage
or approximating it.
But I absolutely love the idea.
We've got a great bonus show today.
We'll, we'll talk about fighting, picking
up in Afghanistan after talks have collapsed.
We will talk about a study that has sound,
a correlation between daytime naps and heart
health, but is it a causal relationship?
And also we see Nancy Pelosi trying to split
Trump and Republicans over drug pricing in
a way that quite frankly does not strike me
as super effective, but we'll talk about it
and more on today's books,
Ms. Show two ways to access it.
Become a member@joinpackmandotcomorapatronatpatriondotcomslashdavidthedavidpakmanshowatdavidpakman.com.